mit jeder spritze die hier aufgezogen
wird rückt das ende der pandemie ein
stückchen näher
sie sind heiß begehrt denn sie bringen
freiheiten zurück in der arztpraxis von
dr heinz ebbinghaus sind soest wird die
impfung bescheinigt wie eh und je auf
einem gelben stück papier das ist jetzt
ein ganz normaler impfausweis ein
internationaler impfausweis aber sie
sehen er ist einfach aus papier
wie kann ich blättern ja er ist absolut
nicht fälschungssicher
ich kann dir den aufkleber tragen
aufkleben
ja und das kann ich nur ich das können
auch viele andere die nicht dazu befugt
sind im netz und bei chat dienste bieten
betrüger gefälschte interesse an dieser
hier für 100 euro ein ganzes set mit
vier aufklebern und stempeln für 700
euro
die bundesregierung und ihr
gesundheitsminister hatten schon vor
wochen angekündigt für jeden werde es
einen fälschungssicheren digital
impfpass geben der in europa gilt bis
mitte mai
der termin ist verstrichen es bleibt bei
meiner aussage zweite hälfte des zweiten
quartals die hat am montag begonnen und
das heißt in den nächsten wochen
warum es so lange dauert sind wie gesagt
die technischen vorgaben die
europäischen abstimmung die sommerferien
beginnen in manchen bundesländern in
knapp vier wochen
tatsächlich ist der digitale empfang
bisher nur in wenigen ländern
wirklichkeit dänemark und schweden haben
ihn griechenland estland und israel auf
sonst fehlanzeige deutschland ist noch
nicht so weit
nur der landkreis altötting 93 kilometer
hinter münchen
der hat den digitalen impfpass für seine
bürger schon anfang januar eingeführt
das impfzentrum des landkreises in einem
eigens aufgebauten holzhaus wird jedem
nach der zweiten impfung ein digitaler
impfpass ausgestellt auf einer
plastikkarte mit foto und qr code
routine seit januar entscheiden diese im
prinzip nicht immer wie lange etwas
dauert sondern dass man rechtzeitig
beginnt das heißt also man muss
natürlich zur erkenntnis kommen das ist
notwendig und zu dieser erkenntnis sind
wir schon im oktober letzten jahres
gekommen
der wurde bei uns noch darüber
diskutiert oder in deutschland darüber
diskutiert ob überhaupt genug leute zur
impfung gehen
aufwand und kosten für den digitalen
empfang in altötting überschaubar also
ein digitaler impfausweis kostet von den
materialkosten der vielleicht zehn oder
15 cent hinzu kommen natürlich auch die
arbeitskosten also wir beschäftigen da
schon zehn leute damit also das heißt
die personalkosten geschlagen in der tat
zu buche aber das ist alles billig
gegenüber den schäden die praktisch
durch kroner verursacht werden also das
ist sehr sehr günstig zu haben
der marienwallfahrtsort altötting zu
pfingsten wo normalerweise pilger die
straßen füllen galten bis vor wenigen
tagen strenge ausgangssperren nun sind
zumindest die biergärten wieder offen
doch nur für getestete genießen und
geimpft
die einheimischen freuen sich über den
digitalen vorsprung recht schönes ding
funktioniert hervorragend ist ganz toll
organisiert die gäste nach der zweiten
impfung rhein wird fotografiert klappt
hervorragend ist hervorragend
organisiert und praktisch perfekt schaut
so aus der cranger karten und den hass
immer dabei ist hat ja nicht jeder
digital handy etc
und das heißt halt dabei ich finde dann
sollten sie überall in deutschland
einfach weil dann haben eine
einheitliche regelung
jeder kann dann mitnehmen werden möchte
sind dort angebracht worden sind also
groß und kompliziert machen wir unsere
regierung ein
bisschen kompliziert bleibt es auch in
altötting denn auch ein digitaler
impfpass muss vorgezeigt und überprüft
werden
auch im biergarten gastwirt udo leipold
ist es leid den kontrolleur zu spielen
die kontrolle für diese ganzen sachen
schwierig zumal ich noch nicht
hundertprozentig weiß was ich alles
kontrollieren muss und kontrollieren
darf und kontrollieren soll wissen dass
die mädels oder jungs die hier arbeiten
bist du das machbar sein das geht nicht
also das ist einfach ein bisschen zu
viel des guten
jörg schieb beobachtet seit 1985 wie
deutschland versuchte digital
mitzuhalten
es ist wie so oft auch beim digitalen
impfpass dauert es zu lange betens im
sommer vergangenen jahres war ja klar es
wird einen impfstoff geben und wir
werden impfen müssen spätestens dann
hätte man sich überlegen müssen wie
machen wir das eigentlich mit der mit
dem digitalen impfnachweis beispiel
handlung war papierne hilfe unterlagen
palettenweise deutschlandweit werden
dass bis ende juni um 22 millionen sein
das zu digitalisieren vor dem
sommerurlaub zu schaffen
ein totales chaos für die arztpraxen für
die impfzentren unnötig übrigens auch
und auch teuer und selbstverständlich
erst recht für die bürgerinnen und
bürger das chaos diese verunsicherung
diese zumutung übrigens auch hätte
vermieden werden können
der bundesgesundheitsminister aber
verbreitet zuversicht
deshalb machen wir ausdrücklich möglich
dass neben arztpraxen und impfzentren
auch apothekerinnen und apotheker für
bereits geimpfte den digitalen empfang
ausweis ausstellen können die
ärzteverbände halten davon nichts
zutaten klargestellt die hausärzte
machen da nicht mit
wir sehen ja was unsere niedergelassenen
ärztinnen und ärzte gerade leisten und
die sind ganz oben jetzt langsam
angekommen
hier muss dann kleben bleibt sind ja
auch die medizinischen fachangestellten
die muss man an der stelle auch noch mal
hervorheben das sind diejenigen die in
den praxen ganz viel arbeiten mit
leisten die laufen schon an der grenze
und dem kann man das nicht noch aufs
auge drücken das zu machen
in den apotheken sind viele mitarbeiter
bis heute selbst nicht geimpft jetzt
sollen gerade dort digitale impfpässe
ausgestellt werden schneller und
preiswerter wird es dadurch
wahrscheinlich nicht das muss
entsprechend honoriert werden
wir müssen uns darauf vorbereiten mit
aufwendungen mit personalaufwendungen
und natürlich auch mit raumbedarf und
wir dürfen da ja unsere hauptaufgabe
nicht die arzneimittelversorgung der
bevölkerung nicht erst im auge verlieren
das ist das wichtigste was wir machen
müssen
wir gehen nicht von unschönen szenen aus
aber wir können uns schon vorstellen
dass es wartezeiten gibt in den
apotheken bis dieser impfausweis
generiert ist halt budget der kleine
landkreis hat seit anfang des jahres was
deutschland nach wie vor fehlt einen
digitalen impfpass das hätte nicht so
kommen müssen wenn er damals auch
kritisiert worden dass sich die
gesellschaft spalten wir die metro eine
idee und keiner hat daran gedacht dass
natürlich jeder das grundrecht auf seine
freiheiten wieder hat das war einfach
von der bundesregierung zu wenig
proaktiv gedacht und auch gehandelt
[Musik]